10 Amazing Fan Theories That Drastically Change
Kids Movies!
Subscribe to our channel : http://goo.gl/ho3Hg6
Check Out These Other Amazing Videos:
The Secret Relations Between Disney Movie
Princesses https://youtu.be/t-KP9FoROZc
10 Movie Theories That Completely Change Popular
Films https://youtu.be/rw7FQ4uU-qo
As nice as it is to think that movies made
for kids aren't bogged down with secret meanings
or dark themes, movie fans can see their childhood
favourites in a completely different light
once they take a second look.
Whether it's intended or not, these theories
are too good to leave unexamined.
Wait until you hear the last one, you won’t
even believe it!
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Movie Theories That
Completely Change Children's Films.
Script by: Andrew Dyce @andrewbdyce
Voice Over by: Rob Flis @Rob_Flis
https://twitter.com/rob_flis
Featuring:
Peter Pan | 0:26
Finding Nemo | 0:57
Back To The Future | 1:31
Willy Wonka |
Star Wars |
Toy Story |
Spider-Man |
Harry Potter |
Home Alone |
Our Social Media:
https://twitter.com/screenrant
https://www.facebook.com/ScreenRant
https://plus.google.com/+ScreenRant
Our Website
http://screenrant.com/
Screen Rant, All Your TV and Movie News In
List Video Form!
Movie Secrets, Hidden Clues, Superheroes,
Movie Mistakes, Car Chases, Deleted Scenes,
Plot Holes, Unscripted Scenes, Hidden Messages
And Much More!
As nice as it is to think that movies made
for kids aren't bogged down with secret meanings
or dark themes, movie fans can see their childhood
favourites in a completely different light
once they take a second look.
Whether it's intended or not, these theories
are too good to leave unexamined.
Wait until you hear the last one, you won’t
even believe it!
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Movie Theories That
Completely Change Children's Films.
Peter Pan
When people think Disney mermaids, the ones
in the animated version of Neverland aren't
the first ones that come to mind.
But they were the first, showing their talent
for trouble making, a distrust of mortals,
and a fear of pirates.
And one of them looks an awful lot like Ariel,
the Star of The Little Mermaid.
So much, that fans have theorized that it's
actually Ariel's mother, Athena.
The mother isn't introduced until the straight
to video sequel, where she is eventually killed
by - you guessed it - pirates.
If the theory is true, then she really should
have stayed in Neverland.
Finding Nemo
It's a happy story, but Finding Nemo begins
with a heartbreaking scene, as Nemo's mother
is killed along with the rest of her eggs,
leaving Nemo to be raised by his father, Marlon.
At least, that's what you're meant to think.
But after watching Marlon's whole adventure,
some have pointed out that it's a close parallel
to the stages of grief - as in, the way he
would have to come to terms with losing Nemo,
too.
Was Marlon searching for an imaginary son
the entire time, unable to accept that he'd
lost his entire family?
There isn't much actual evidence to support
it in the story, but it's too dark to not
mention.
Back to the Future
Nobody ever asked how a teenage boy and an
elderly scientist and failed inventor became
best friends, but there wasn't much time before
Doc Brown sent Marty McFly back in time to
wonder.
But take a closer look at the DeLorean's first
trip through time: Doc makes Marty stand beside
him staring down the speeding car, with it
disappearing just in time.
Since every other one of his inventions failed,
fans claim, he would've had to think the same
might happen here.
Apparently, Doc had reached his breaking point,
making sure that if this invention was also
a bust, he wouldn't live to make another.
And he'd be taking Marty with him.
Talk about heavy.
Willy Wonka
Even fans would agree: there is something
very off about Willy Wonka.
But some people claim that Wonka isn't just
weird, but a cold blooded killer.
He never seems too surprised when the children
on his factory tour wind up hurt or possibly
killed, or even upset.
Once fans realized that his Oompa Loompas
would have needed time to rehearse their songs,
describing which children were harmed, and
how, the theory was complete: long before
the Saw movies (Use Still), there was Willy
Wonka, and his chocolate factory death trap
- only kids allowed.
Star Wars
You don't have to be a kid to love Star Wars,
but George Lucas clearly hoped that one character
in his prequel trilogy, Jar Jar Binks would
be a hit with young fans.
Instead, he became a punching bag for the
prequels as a whole.
But what if fans were right to hate the Gungan
klutz?
It may sound like a long shot, but the theory
that Jar Jar was faking his stupidity, and
working for the Dark Side all along has gained
a lot of steam.
The “Darth Jar Jar” theory even made it
to Lucas himself.
But if it's true that Jar Jar and the Emperor
were working together all along, he's not
letting the secret out any time soon.
Toy Story
The toys take the spotlight in Pixar's series,
but there are humans, too: Andy, the boy who
owns the toys, and his mother and sister.
But most fans have wondered about Andy's father.
It's nothing new for a Disney movie to have
a parent or two out of the picture, but it's
never explained, or even mentioned.
Some fans have taken that fact as a sign that
Andy's father either left the family, or passed
away long before the first movie - explaining
his connection to strong, honourable, father
figure dolls like Buzz and Woody.
One Pixar writer has supported that idea,
so this theory isn't as far fetched as some
might think.
Spider-Man
It may not be a kids movie but Spider-Man
remains extremely popular with today’s youth.
Peter Parker's journey from geek to superhero
is a dream come true for every comic book
nerd, but when he hit the big screen, some
fans think it was a more universal story being
told.
Peter doesn't start getting powers until he
hits high school, when he starts getting serious
feelings for a childhood crush, grows into
a man's body overnight, and starts spending
more and more time alone in his room.
It seems a pretty clear metaphor for boys
hitting puberty, at least that's what some
claim.
Even without the sticky webbing, it's a hard
case to argue.
Harry Potter
Most of the magical spells in the Harry Potter
series were created from scratch, but the
most evil curse actually sounds familiar.
But why would The Killing Curse sound just
like "Abra cadabra," one of the most well
known magic spells in the world?
Fans have connected the dots, deducing that
wizards and witches weren't always kind to
Muggles (those are non magic people for non
harry potter fans!), some imagining they even
killed everyday people for sport.
More optimistic fans claim the curse was used
to kill infections before Muggles got wise
to magic, so fans can take their pick.
But it isn't just Harry Potter who makes out
like the hero of the series, thanks to one
fan theory based directly on the books.
Most fans will remember Neville Longbottom
as a bumbling, but lovable sidekick who eventually
let his good heart make up for his lack of
magic.
But remember: a wizard's wand matters too
- that's why it's supposed to choose its user.
But Neville chose to use his father's wand
instead, which was probably the reason for
his disastrous magic.
It was only after he purchased a wand of his
own that he joined Dumbledore's Army, battled
Death Eaters and became an all around top
tier wizard.
It turns out Neville was a master spellcaster
the entire time.
Home Alone
We've saved the most incredible theory for
last.
Everyone knows how Kevin McCallister survived
a Christmas home alone, using paint cans,
nails, tar and blowtorches to turn his house
into a torture chamber for two attempted burglars.
But it wasn't his last.
That's right, some fans believe Kevin grew
up to become Jigsaw, the murderous mastermind
of the Saw movie series.
Once you factor in Kevin's serious rage issues,
it's the best kind of theory.
One that makes both movies seem even more
amazing - whether it's true or not.
Those are some of the most entertaining and
convincing theories based on kids' movies
that we've found, but which ones have we missed?
Let us know in the comments, and be sure to
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one.